jacques mesrine abattu par la police cet
après midi à paris moscou nouvelles
arrestations de dissidents avant les
jeux olympiques les palestiniens et
l'europe
yasser arafat reçue officiellement à
lisbonne
dans la mesure bons soirs 15h15 cet
après midi porte de clignancourt à paris
au milieu de la circulation
une fusillade éclate une voiture grise
s'immobilise criblé de balles à
l'intérieur tu es net
jacques mesrine et sa compagne
grièvement blessé par les policiers de
l'office central de répression du
banditisme qui avait tendu un véritable
guet-apens à celui qui depuis plus d'un
an et demi faisait courir et narguer
toutes les polices de france avant
d'aller plus loin vous propose de
revivre les événements tels qu'ils se
sont déroulés
chronologiquement cet après midi forte
de clignon c'est ici au milieu de cette
place de clignancourt jacques mary n'a
été abattu à cazères saab et elle
démarre on se faufile dans la
circulation
deux camionnettes de déménagement la
bloque à l'avant et à l'arrière
les rafales de mitraillettes part de
l'arrière de la première camionnette
jacques mérine s'écroule mort sur son
volant sans avoir eu le temps de
dégoupiller les grenades qu'il portait
sur lui
les inspecteurs se précipitent évacue de
la voiture la fiancée des verrines
grièvement blessé trois quarts d'heure
après le corps de jacques mesrine est
transporté hors de la bm v nous avons
relevé 19 a pas eu de balles sur le pare
brise de la voiture
les inspecteurs qui le suivait depuis
plusieurs jours n'ont rien laissé au
hasard
oui rien n'avait été laissé au hasard
c'est d'après midi tous les grands
patrons de la police était là monsieur
ducret patron de la pj de paris le
commissaire broussard de l'antigang et
ils ne cachaient pas leur satisfaction
y'a pas mieux vous servir et non
par la foi bien passé
j'insiste il y avait les deux services y
avait des deux services pour crb est
terrible les 19 balles mortelles je
savais le crb outil de répression du
banditisme de la berbie brega l'antigang
les rivalités entre les deux yeux de
catherine d'oublier au milieu d'une
foule de policiers de journalistes et de
témoins voilà j'ai vu quelqu'un sur le
voulons bien blessé je ne savais pas qui
est ce qui s'est passé c'est à ce moment
là que plusieurs voitures civiles 700
arrêté son coin c'est cette bmw et
plusieurs jeunes en blouson que je ne
savais pas qui c'était 7 après que je me
suis rendu compte
ils avaient tous des brassards ce sens
mis par terre parce qu'ils croyaient
peut-être que le blessé allait avoir des
réactions et il se sent vite levés ils
ont entouré la voiture et à ce moment là
c'était plein de voitures de police
étaient pleins auparavant il y avait
rien d'anormal y avait juste un
ascenseur césaire le décès de l'ennemi
public numéro 1 est terminée
souvenez vous il ya presque un an et
demi jacques mesrine s'échappe une
nouvelle fois de façon spectaculaire de
la prison de la santé depuis
il narguait toutes les polices de france
recommençant à voler à prendre en otage
et à se comporter comme il disait
comme un justicier à plusieurs reprises
les policiers avaient été à deux doigts
de l'arrêté cette fois ci ils ne l'ont
pas ratée ils étaient trente inspecteurs
de l'office central de répression du
banditisme est membre de la brigade anti
gang comme l'a souligné tout à l'heure
le commissaire broussard sous les ordres
du commissaire bouvier qui depuis
quelques mois avait pris en mains toutes
ses recherches il y a dix jours les
hommes du commissaire bouvier avait
assisté à une rencontre entre mesrine et
l'un de ses complices du milieu charles
bauer recherché pour trafic de drogue et
qui a été aussi arrêtés
aujourd'hui ils ne sont pas intervenus
car le contact se passait dans la rue
mais la filature de mesrine a permis
ensuite de retrouver son domicile il ya
48 heures là encore les policiers ne
sont pas intervenus car il craignait une
prise d'otages ils ont donc à ce
moment-là décidé d'attendre aujourd'hui
écoutons le commissaire bougies
et par conséquence depuis 48 heures nous
étions là tout près intervenez lorsqu'au
début de l'après midi
mesrine est donc sorti nous ne pouvions
pas faire une surveillance pour
approcher pour n'être pas détecter tout
le dispositif de police a à jouer et
c'est un tic au milieu en du de la place
de la porte de clignancourt toutes les
autos - de nombreuses voitures de nos
services ont littéralement encerclé la
voiture de mesrine qui se trouvait avec
sa maîtresse nationale à moyens utilisés
aussi grâce aux mollahs si vous voulez
bien vous me laisser raconter à ce
moment là lorsque mesrine s'est vu
entouré de voiture il a en outre ouvert
sa portière
nous savions qu'il avait avec lui des
grenades défensives
effectivement les constatations permis
d'établir qu'il avait dans une sacoche
ouverte à ses pieds deux grenades
défensives à partir selon mena
nous ne pouvions pas le laisser utiliser
ces grenades et nous avons été amenés à
tirer je crois vous avoir raconté les
conditions dans lesquelles nous sommes
intervenus
nous ne pouvions pas permettre à mesrine
de jeter une brega une grenade et sur
nos fonctionnaires et dans la foule ce
n'était pas possible d'autant plus que
je crois devoir vous rappeler que dans
tout ce qu'il a déclaré dans les lettres
qu'il vous a adressé à eux annoncé
qu'ils tireraient sur nous lors du
dernier procès aux assises et en prêts
devant la cour et devant tous les
journalistes il s'est adressé au
commissaire broussard pour gagner la
prochaine fois dans la rue
c'est celui qui tira le prof le premier
qui aura raison enfin lors de la
tentative de remise laurent sont deux
dames martin il a ouvert le feu sur les
voitures de police qui se trouvait
encore à 150 m nous ne pouvions donc
absolument pas permettre que mesrine
recommence il était sorti en levant les
mains la situation va était tout à fait
différente
là il avait les grenades il avait sur
lui un pistolet charger de rechange et
sans s'assurer que nous avions à prendre
de risques
la suite des évènements de cet après
midi le premier ministre a demandé au
ministre de l'intérieur de transmettre
ses félicitations aux policiers aux
gendarmes qui ont participé à la
recherche de jacques mesrine monsieur
bonnet lui avait tenu vous venez de
l'entendre à ce que ce soit monsieur
bouvier lui même qui explique aux
journalistes comment il avait organisé
ses recherches pour en revenir à la fait
à proprement dit si pendant longtemps
jacques mesrine avait pu échapper aux
recherches c'est que l'action des
policiers des gendarmes dépendant de
plusieurs directions de plusieurs
services qui souvent signoret c'est pour
cette raison qu'il ya quelques mois le
commissaire bouvier avait été chargé de
coordonner l'ensemble des recherches et
c'est sans doute en grande partie grâce
à cette décision que l'on a pu arriver à
la conclusion d'aujourd'hui
c'est en 1961 souvenez vous il ya
presque 20 ans que jacques mesrine
commençait sa carrière de gangsters si
je puis dire vingt années de meurtre de
cavale de hold up qui avait fait de cet
homme de 36 ans un bandit vraiment pas
comme les c'est en mars 1962 à 26 ans
que jacques mesrine fait son entrée dans
les annales judiciaires pour un banal
cambriolage qui lui vaut 18 mois de
prison
une fois libéré il retournera bientôt à
la délinquance avec des ambitions
décuplées hold-up pillage d'appartements
et braquages dans les banques premier
règlement de comptes
mesrine dira lui même qu'il est devenu
un tueur sans remords et sans regret
traquée en france ils courent sa chance
au canada après une courte tentative de
retour au travail honnête et il enlève
son ancien employeur il n'arrivera pas à
toucher la rançon à cause de la
défaillance d'un complice mais le voilà
hisser parmi les grands du banditisme
international
il est pourtant arrêté deux ans plus
tard en 71 alors nouveau coup d'éclat il
réussit à s'évader de la prison de haute
sécurité de montréal avec cinq autres
détenus
puis il pousse l'audace jusqu'à attaquer
ce même pénitencier les armes à la main
pour tenter de libérer les amis qu'il
s'y était fait c'est un échec mais après
cette action sans précédent
le cas mesrine est posé il n'est pas un
truand ordinaire septembre 72,2
garde-chasse sont tués dans la forêt
québécoise
ce sont les deux seuls meurtre
officiellement attribué à misery il
rentre en france ou en mars 73 il est
arrêté on ne le gardera que trois mois
il avait préparé d'avancé les moyens de
son évasion des armes cachées au palais
de justice de compiègne lui permettent
de prendre en otage le président du
tribunal
il réussit à s'enfuir il est maintenant
l'ennemi public numéro un trois mois de
liberté seulement le 28 septembre 73 la
brigade antigang le cueille au gîte à
paris il offre le champagnes commissaire
broussard une des rares personnes qu'il
dit respecter et qu'il désigne
volontiers comme un grand flic pendant
la langue d'instruction de son procès
trois ans et demi il écrit un livre
l'instinct de mort où il revendique 39
meurtre alors même qu'il n'est pas
encore jugé
gros succès de vente la justice est
bloqué les droits d'auteur plus de 500
mille francs au total 19 mai 1977
jacques mesrine est condamné à 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle après un procès de
quatorze jours le voilà à la santé la
prison dont on ne s'évade pas il est
placé dans un cachet ce quartier de
haute sécurité
réservé aux grands criminels réputé
dangereux oui mais pour un an seulement
le 8 mai soixante dix huit la prison de
la santé perd sa réputation
mesrine s'évade du hs avec son ami
françois bès un troisième compagnon
d'évasion karman rive est tué sur place
au coin de la rue de la santé vous avez
la casquette et puis avec cette espèce
de blousons comme les matons c'est
pareil je discute avec la violence on
m'a dit on pas que j'en reviens de loin
le plus sa place
mesrine oui c'est sûr fenech était bon
enfant des armes et tout un matériel
avait été cachée dans le parloir du cul
hs mesrine a donc bénéficié de
complicités multiples dix jours plus
tard
hold up au casino de deauville mesrine
est blessé d'une balle à la hanche juin
ils vident la caisse de la société
générale au raincy il avait d'abord pris
en otage chez lui à son domicile
le fondé de pouvoir et l'avait contraint
à l'accompagner jusqu'à la banque nous a
dit qu'il voulait pas lui qui nourrit
pas moi qui lui ai simplement de
l'argent mais pas d'ici ni à nous
novembre 78 prise d'otage manquer chez
monsieur petit président de la cour
d'assises de paris
c'est pour protester contre l'existence
des quartiers de haute sécurité dans les
prisons où l'on transforme dit il des
hommes en faut en juin enlèvement dans
ville-es-lièvre l'octogénaire
milliardaire de la sarthe
mesrine le libère le 28 juillet contre
une rançon de 6 millions
il a désormais les poches pleines un
autre en profiterait pour tenter de
disparaître pas lui le 10 septembre 79
il accepte un rendez vous avec jacques
tillier journaliste à minute près de
creil dans une carrière désaffectée il
le bleis de trois balles il écrit aux
journaux j'ai voulu punir tillier par
ses écrits par ces messages ou ces
menaces aux journaux les interviews
données
ces déclarations lors de son procès il a
veillé à construire son personnage à
nourrir sa légende
mais saura-t-on jamais le ressorts
secrets de cette vie errante courageux
sans doute mais bâti sur le crime et un
définitif gâcher une réponse est
peut-être donné par le titre du récit
qu'il en a fait l'instinct de mort
jacques mesrine est donc mort cet
après-midi abattu par des policiers
c'est d'ailleurs comme cela qu'il
décrivait sa mort dans le livre qu'il
avait écrit en prison certains le
considérer comme une sorte de robin des
bois des temps modernes d'autres comme
un vulgaire gangster un criminel cela
dit ce soir
quoi que l'on ait pu penser de jacques
mesrine c'est la fin d'une légende
peuvent en effet mesrine est mort comme
il l'avait prévu et que mettait fin à
quatre fatale que beaucoup de prévoit
bien sûr un certain nombre de policiers
lisez qu'il serait préférable de le
prendre vivant pour afin qu'un grand
procès public en cour d'assises puisse
mieux concrétisait la réussite de la
police pourquoi pas la revanche d'un
homme que mesrine a largement bafouée et
avant que ne se lève véritable querelle
les sommations et juste de rappeler que
l'interpellation au lieu d'une foule
d'un homme comme mesrine parfaitement
déterminé à ne pas retourner en prison
soulever quelques dures problèmes de
sécurité pour les passants c'est donc la
fin d'un mythe mais pas celle d'un héros
de feuilleton grand élégant doué d'une
facilité d'expression et d'un quotient
intellectuel largement supérieure à la
mienne de truands la dépendance et son
procès en cour d'assises
mesrine avait toujours cultivé un côté
robin des bois du genre je n'attaque aux
banques et aux riches une image qui
gomme est en quelque sorte d'autres
aspects plus brutaux et moins délétère
désintéresser de son caractère mais
c'était aussi une image qui flattait
faut le dire le goût un peu frondeur des
français qui emmènent leurs enfants
voire guignols battre les gendarmes en
oubliant l'assassin mesrine n'était pas
un héros pas non plus le tueur pervers
qui tueur pour le plaisir
il était devenu en quelque sorte la
démonstration vivant
de la question que se posent toujours
les criminologues mais pourquoi un homme
que rien ne prédispose au crime
devient-il criminelle la démonstration
aussi d'une faille dans l'efficacité
d'une police qui c'est vrai a beaucoup
de choses à faire avec des moyens plutôt
limité mesrine démontrer au grand jour
l'absence d'un certain nombre de
priorités en hommes et en matériel et
c'est parce que ses priorités ont enfin
été reconnu que mesrine a perdu la
partie
si on s'en souvient ministre in our au
moins aura servi à quelque chose
nous reviendrons bien sûr en détail sur
cette affaire mesrine dans notre
dernière édition ce soir présenté par
paul hamm le premier ministre du québec
monsieur rené lévesque va demander par
référendum aux québécois de le mandaté
pour négocier avec le gouvernement
fédéral la souveraineté de la province
qui resterait tout de même associé avec
le canada une proposition qui provoque
une réaction immédiate ce soir du
premier ministre monsieur clark qui
déclare n'avoir aucunement l'intention
de discuter de cette proposition avec
monsieur lévesque tout au moins sur les
bases actuelles
je vous l'annoncé hier soir trois
dissidents soviétiques ont été arrêtés
dans la capitale de l'urss moscou selon
le témoignage de cet réfugiés russes que
vous allez entendre qu'ils étaient en
relation avec les personnes arrêtées ces
décisions des autorités soviétiques
marque le début d'une purge visant à
faire en quelque sorte le vide de
contestataires dans moscou avant les
jeux olympiques vous attendiez des
arrestations
nous ne savions pas qui sera là
c'est une sorte de purge devant les jeux
olympiques et je pense que il ya aussi
une raison
tous les trois personnes arrêtées donc
délicat nova le perg la beac union et
internationale ce cas ce sont des
personnes qui n'avaient pas envie
d'émigrer
donc il ne pourrait pas les comprendre
d'émigrer donc il fallait les éliminer
pas de l'arrestation est ce que votre
avis une pression internationale peut
influer les autorités soviétiques
je voudrais et je ne fais pas dire il
faut bien sûr il faut faire la campagne
de publicité de l'opinion publique et
cetera mais quelque chose ou pas oui oui
on peut éviter d autres arrestations
parce que je suis sûr que c'est 3 à la
station n'est qu'un début
et cette perche au lendemain du 25e
anniversaire de la révolution algérienne
monsieur giscard d'estaing a transmis un
message au président chadli pour le chef
de l'état français le dialogue entre les
deux pays doit se renforcer ainsi que la
coopération à laquelle une impulsion
nouvelle doit être donné la véritable
vedette de ces cérémonies d'alger aura
été monsieur yasser arafat le leader
palestinien qui a profité de ce séjour
pour relancer son offensive diplomatique
qui semble être la nouvelle tactique
adoptée par le fbi
en effet la nuit dernière dans la
capitale algérienne monsieur arafat a
participé à un sommet du front de la
fermeté regroupant les pays arabes
hostiles aux accords entre l'egypte et
israël
ensuite poursuivant sa démarche vers
l'europe il a rencontré monsieur georges
marchais qui au nom du parti communiste
français a réaffirmé le désir du pc de
voir le gouvernement français invités
yasser arafat et puis enfin le leader de
l'olp et s'est envolé pour lisbonne
bruneval
yasser arafat à son arrivée à lisbonne
le président de l'ol fès après c'est ce
qui c'est un fils supplémentaire dans la
toile d'araignée diplomatiques déployés
depuis quelques mois par l'organisation
palestinienne le but renforcer la
représentativité de west bay en europe
occidentale
d'ailleurs s'il ya sert arafat était
officiellement attendu par les
organisateurs d'une conférence mondiale
de solidarité avec le peuple arabe sur
le thème de la palestine ce sont bien
les conversations avec un responsable
politique portugais qui constitue
l'essentiel de son activité à lillebonne
ici avec le premier ministre madame
lourdes est assez legault et peut-être
avec le président de la république rend
maloya neige qu'il pourrait dit on
rencontré avant son départ de lisbonne
dimanche il y assez rare a fat osera des
jalons en vue de l'installation dans la
capitale portugaise d'une nouvelle
représentation de l'om les rencontres
avec le socialiste mario soares et aussi
avec le communiste alvaro cunhal
viennent s'ajouter au rendez-vous que
yasser arafat avait déjà honoré à vienne
est ici à madrid en septembre dernier
répondant ainsi à un souci primordial
celui d'occuper au mieux et de la façon
la plus large qui soit la scène
diplomatique
mes dernières précisions apportées à ce
sujet notons que la france n'a toujours
pas dit son intention d'inviter monsieur
yasser arafat officiellement en france
le ton monte en israël après la décision
du gouvernement hier d'accepter le
démantèlement d'une colonie sauvage de
cisjordanie l'un des ministres de
monsieur begin monsieur sharon hostiles
au démantèlement de ce village affirme
aujourd'hui dans une interview que tout
risque de confrontation entre militaires
chargés d'exécuter l'ordre et les
pionniers du village n'est pas à exclure
vous avez d'ailleurs vu la vie de ce
village et ses habitants hier soir dans
ce journal en bolivie après le coup
d'état dit hier le nouveau gouvernement
militaire a prêté serment
l'état de siège a été instauré et le
colonel bosh auteur du coup d'état a
annoncé et qu'il s'apprêtait à convoquer
une assemblée constituante j'ajouterai à
cela deux dépêches qui viennent de
tomber d'abord des barricades montées
étaient élevées aujourd'hui à la passe
par des jeunes étudiants mais ils ont
été dispersés par la police
une nouvelle encore plus importante pour
l'avenir économique de ce pays
suspension décidée ce soir à washington
de l'aide et
économique et militaire américaine à la
bolivie au laos des troupes
vietnamiennes font route vers la
frontière chinoise pour contrer une
éventuelle offensive de pékin dans ce
climat de guerre
le président en exil de l'ex camp putsch
et à démocratique a envoyé une lettre au
prince norodom sihanouk pour lui
proposer de devenir président de la
république
parallèlement à ces manoeuvres
diplomatiques l'assemblée les nations
unies s'apprêtent à ouvrir un débat sur
l'aide humanitaire que le monde peut
apporter à 6 millions d'hommes de femmes
et d'enfants qui meurent de faim une
réunion qui s'annonce difficile car
l'urss la chine le vietnam et le nouveau
régime de phnom penh seront présents
autant dire qu'il sera très difficile
d'éviter la politique et voir la
politique c'est pourtant ce que voudrait
le ministre des affaires étrangères
monsieur français monsieur jean
françois-poncet invités d'antenne 2010
le ministre a précisé les chiffres de
l'aide de la france et de l'europe au
peuple cambodgien
le secrétaire général des nations-unies
a fait des évaluations et l'europe syrie
à la demande de la france pour apporter
une réponse commune
je peux vous dire que c'est très posh
sera de l'ordre de la moitié tout ce
qu'ils demandent c'est à dire si on
parle c'est à dire qu'il ya 110 millions
de dollars et l'europe apportera en gros
50 5 millions $ se mettent à quoi le
taux allemand la france ajoutera une
aide bilatérale complémentaires dans un
salon de l'auto mais c'est le premier
point
le second point qui est plus important
que le premier c'est celui de
l'acheminement et de la distribution
c'est ça qui est crucial c'est ça qui
est difficile est ce que je demande
c'est que tous les moyens de transport
soit employé l'avion ce qui est déjà le
cas mais avec l'ouverture à la
circulation aérienne humanitaire de
nouveaux héros le fleuve le mais comme
la mer naturellement pour arriver et je
pense que si il devait apparaître que la
situation est trop critique et que
l'acheminement des aides et roland alors
je pense que la communauté
internationale avec naturellement
l'accord des parties sur le terrain
devrait envisager l'hypothèse de
parachute à l'occasion de cet entretien
monsieur jean françois poncet a rendu
hommage dans un tout autre domaine à
monsieur robert boulin qui était je cite
monsieur pons est dans le gouvernement
l'un des plus complets
temps l'un des plus capable et des plus
courtois et d'une netteté irréprochable
c'est pourquoi a ajouté le ministre sa
disparition me bouleverse
de là à dire je cite toujours monsieur
françois poncet qui est une crise
politique ou une crise de société
je crois que c'est tout à fait excessif
fin de citation
les obsèques du ministre du travail
auront lieu demain dans son village
natal le président de la république sera
représentée par monsieur jacques valse
fait taire général de l'elysée et
monsieur raymond barre premier ministre
représentera le gouvernement
ce matin la dépouille mortelle de
l'ancien ministre du travail avait été
transporté par avion jusqu'à libourne
dont il était le maire jean-michel
mercure à une brève cérémonie tôt ce
matin sur l'aéroport militaire de
villacoublay pour rendre les honneurs
aux ministres disparu quatre membres du
gouvernement y assistaient alain
peyrefitte garde des sceaux jean
philippe lecat ministre de la culture et
deux secrétaires d'état
jean-pierre prouteau et jean farges la
fille de monsieur boulin son gendre et
quelques proches d'amis du ministre du
travail devait ensuite prendre place à
bord du nord 262 qui ramenait vers
bordeaux
la dépouille mortelle
sur l'aéroport de mérignac
le conseil municipal de libourne au
grand complet était venu saluer son
maire puis le cercueil drapé de
tricolore est transporté à libourne où
attendent déjà une foule nombreuse et il
est exposé dans une chapelle ardente à
l'hôtel de ville plusieurs milliers de
libournais ont alors rendu un dernier
hommage silencieux à celui qui l'avait
porté pendant 20 ans à la tête des
destinées de leur ville et qui était
aussi leurs députés
à libourne la consternation est telle
qu'on a encore du mal à imaginer le
suicide de robert boulin un homme dont
on dit il était si équilibré si joyeux
si combatif la dépouille de robert
boulin repose ce soir à villandraut où
ses obsèques auront lieu demain
dernières informations ce soir à propos
de cette affaire le procureur de la
république de paris a été chargée de
l'enquêté ordonnée par le garde des
sceaux monsieur peyrefitte sur
l'éventuelle violation du secret de
l'instruction dénoncé par la lettre de
monsieur robert boulin c'est ce qu'ont
indiqué que ce soit dans un communiqué
de la chancellerie
depuis ce soir dernière chose dans notre
dernière édition tout de suite après
l'émission apostrophes alain duhamel
consacrera sa chronique hebdomadaire
justement à cette affaire robert boulin
situation confuse à belfort dans le
confit alstom l'usiné toujours occupée
malgré cela la commission de
conciliation s'est réunie cet après midi
enfin une manifestation a eu lieu dans
les rues de la ville et une délégation a
été reçue par le préfet et puis on
m'indique à l'instant que demain
normalement des négociations directes
pourrait commencer devrait commencer
entre les patrons d'alstom atlantique et
les syndicats ce qui devrait peut-être
améliorer les choses grève des
aiguilleurs du ciel
le mouvement continue de perturber le
trafic aérien en france demain
l'aéroport d'orly risque de risque
d'être très sérieusement touchés par ces
arrêts de travail qui ont lieu selon le
système des mouvements tournants avec ce
soir aussi dans cette affaire un
communiqué du ministère des transports
qui indique que le mouvement des
contrôleurs aériens qui consiste à
refuser
je cite le communiqué du ministère des
transports consiste à refuser les
autorisation de décollage est contraire
aux lois de la république
c'est ce qu'indique le ministre des
transports et constitue une faute
professionnelle
cette position du ministère intervient
au moment où les organisations
syndicales comme je viens de vous le
dire continuent leur action tout au
moins jusqu'à mardi prochain british
leyland en angleterre chrysler aux états
unis deux monstres sacrés de
l'automobile mondiale en très graves
difficultés vont mettre en oeuvre des
plans de sauvetage qui par leur
originalité constitue chaque dans chacun
des deux pays
un événement sans précèdent pierre marie
thiesse austin maurice jaguar daimler
rovère triumph mg l'ensemble du seul
grand groupe automobile britannique est
en plein naufrage
pour sauver ce qui peut encore l'être
son président michael edwards se
réclamait l'application d'un remède de
cheval fermeture totale ou partielle de
13 usines et 25 mille suppressions
d'emplois les syndicats étaient contre
monsieur edouard ça alors consulter
directement les 159 salariés par
référendum à bulletins secrets
les ouvriers ont répondu oui à 96% des
votants
ils ont manifestement préféré désavoué
leur syndicat que risquez une fermeture
totale du groupe
pour mettre en oeuvre son plan la
direction doit encore obtenir une aide
publique de 250 millions de livres et
négocier avec le personnel dans ce
contexte syndical sans précédent les
vingt-cinq mille suppressions d'emplois
prévues ce ne sera pas facile
chrysler des charges et du poids de sa
branche européenne aujourd'hui talbot
s'est replié sur les états unis mais
continue à perdre de l'argent
460 millions de dollars en trois mois à
ce rythme le troisième constructeur
américain était condamnée sans espoir
réponse hier du président carter et son
secrétaire au trésor williams muller une
série de près d'1 milliard et demi de
dollars garanti par l'état bien que
cette aide soit subordonnée au
financement par la chrysler elle-même
d'un autre milliard et demi de dollars
une intervention aussi massive de l'état
pour renflouer une entreprise privée et
sans précédent aux états unis le
traumatisme économique d'une éventuelle
faillite de chrysler les inconvénients
d'un monopole à deux ford general motors
et aussi la crainte de cinq cent mille
chômeurs supplémentaires à un an des
élections
tout cela sans doute décider
l'administration carter a payé le prix
fort pour ce sauvetage
l'inflation n'est pas une personne même
pas la chine où les prix alimentaires
exception faite du riz et des céréales
viennent d'être augmenté de 30% depuis
hier officiellement cette mesure vise à
réduire l'écart des revenus entre les
villes et les campagnes ne sera compensé
que partiellement par une subvention
accordée aux ouvriers et aux employés
les grandes banques ne se bat plus pour
acheter de l'or à n'importe quel prix
c'est la première leçon du moins que
l'on peut tirer de la vente aux enchères
de 38 tonnes d'heures effectuées par le
trésor américain pour essayer de calmer
les cours du métal précieux
le prix de vente n'a guère dépassé que
72 dollars l'once
et aujourd'hui l'or a fléchi c'était le
résultat escompté sur tous les grands
marchés londres et zurich à paris le
lingot a perdu 300 francs ce qui n'est
déjà pas si mal
théâtre pour terminer ce journal par un
souffle culturel robert hossein qui n'a
pas peur des grandes machines on se
souvient de potemkine répète en ce
moment danton et robespierre au palais
des congrès une fresque sur la terreur
les droits de l'homme et les
conventionnels de 1793 avec 80 comédiens
pas mon en avant première je vous
propose de regarder ce reportage de
georges bigot sursis répétition georges
bigot qui participera demain à
l'émission samedi ennemis présenté par
jean claude mongeau en direct du palais
des congrès avec robert hossein
alain decaux on y parlera bien sûr de la
pièce mais aussi de
histoire et de son enseignement à
l'école mais tout de suite un extrait de
danton et robespierre 9 fermina de rang
de signer sa juste songy bien une tête
comme celle plus quand on en fera couler
beaucoup d'autres je suis dans ce comité
chargé des subsistances
j'y suis pour nourrir les citoyens non
pour tuer les patriotes
le comité de sûreté générale applaudi au
texte de saint gilles et applaudit des
deux mains quand on est un chancre aux
flancs de la république
je demande qu'on intervienne
chirurgicalement et d'urgence
il est bien entendu aux vestiaires que
la station d'antan entraîne celle de des
moulins nous sommes bien d'accord là
dessus on bascule oui va dire alors nous
allons tous signé chacun son ailier moi
ce qui m libre à toi si on frappe le
chèque les indulgents il faut frapper
tous les indulgents regardiez de ne pas
confondre les coupables et les honnêtes
gens badié aujourd'hui l'essentiel c'est
d'en finir avec danton
robert hossein pourquoi aujourd'hui
danton et robespierre
parce que à travers danton et
robespierre ça injuste des moulins et
hébert et une centaine de députés de la
convention nous racontant l'histoire des
hommes
la vie la mort les hommes qui ont les
clés les droits de l'homme parce que
aussi tout le monde aujourd'hui soit van
dyck des droits de l'homme dont les
chics à tout bout de champ ils sont
respectés nulle part et simplement on
voulait rappeler qu'il ya des hommes qui
ont écrit ces articles des droits de
l'homme qui fait que si on les avait
appliqué un jour vivre dans un monde que
d'être un peu meilleur donc si vous
voulez c'est à la fois une grande phrase
sur l'histoire de la convention de la
vie et l'affrontement des danton
robespierre et de tous les députés de
l'époque qui se situe à la fois sur
scène dans la salle partout et qui est à
la fois si vous voulez sans complaisance
dans une objectivité absolu et total
historique l'histoire de ces hommes et
l'histoire de ces droits de l'homme
on sait est un incapable saint général
un caporal
il passe son temps au cabaret se battent
à mort voulait tout est formé à
l'entendre la vendée aurait été nettoyée
en une décade
quant à vincent ce sans culottes qui
fait la loi au ministère de la guerre
il couvre tout le général ronsin et
vincent sont des créatures des verts
rien ne m'étonne données perthus
elle chante entendent perdre la vendée
et l'ipo tu vas me faire le plaisir
d'attaquer cette vermine hébertistes
j'ai fait un rapport au comité où je les
ménages pensent que le lien mais qu'est
ce que tu veux que ça me fasse un
rapport
il y en a déjà 100 milles dans les
armoires du comité de rapports non tout
ce que tu as vu les excès les pillages
l'incurie des généraux s'ils persistent
tu vas me faire le plaisir de l'écrire
philippot de l'écrire pour le publier et
je vais te donne mon billet que tu seras
l'auteur le plus lu transe avec
attaque les rend publiques les chefs qui
commande en vendée sur la risque de
démoraliser les trous kapor que c'est la
paix que nous voulons par héloïse demain
donc c'est nier ni en direct du palais
des congrès avec dans l'ordre danton
robespierre et jean claude mongeau le
temps demain des nuages abondant
affecteront progressivement comme disent
les météorologues les régions voisines
de la manche et de la mer du nord les
vents souffleront d'ouest et seront
assez modéré ailleurs après la
dissipation des brouillards matinaux le
temps sera souvent ensoleillé voilà une
bonne nouvelle
la dernière édition du journal vous sera
présentée par paul amar et demain c'est
léon zitrone en personne que vous
retrouverez ici à ma place à 20h bonsoir
excellente soirée sur antenne 2
à